a romantic comedy this week I'm
branching out let's switch yeah I saw it
I like Jason Bateman I think he's
hilarious oh here we are so the switch
is a story of two people played by Jason
Bateman and Jennifer Aniston who are
pretty much in the friendzone for each
other or rather he's in the friendzone
because girls that we don't put them in
the friendzone they put us in the
friendzone so it's really him and so
Jennifer Aniston wants a kid and she's
gonna do the whole artificial
insemination thing so she's having a
party to celebrate it and Jason Bateman
gets a little blackout shit-faced
hammered Danny accidentally spills the
cup of the artificial insemination
procedure stuff and then he switches it
with his own he beats it in the cup
without her knowing and then the movie
picks up seven years later in which he
has a kid in the romantic comedy ensues
actually I'd more say it's a drama with
Jason Bateman's comedic timing which i
think is awesome dudes hilarious I mean
the cast in this movie is great I mean
Jason Bateman and Jennifer Anderson they
worked really well together and you
really get the feeling that I mean
they're friends but I mean he likes her
more than she likes him you know how it
is dr. Ian Malcolm from Jurassic Park is
Jason Bateman's friend funny I mean the
movie had a lot of witty neurotic dry
humor and when done right that [ __ ]
makes me laugh and the night owl from
Watchmen who plays the donor who doesn't
really know he's kind of not the donor
he was good to now the premise that this
movie is interesting enough for me but I
really like Jason Bateman's character I
mean I'm really nothing like him but I
connected with him in the way that he
views kids do just doesn't really want
him which I mean let's face it they're
really like STDs hold the hate if you
really think about it they are you screw
you get him you're stuck with him STDs
hey I was one once my parents had an STD
they didn't even know it and he was a
pain in the ass but I'll be the first to
admit it this kid this movie is a really
cute kid he's like the Jerry Maguire kid
of now if he came from Jason Bateman
sperm and Jason Bateman starts getting
attached to this kid I mean you do too
and I just it was good whatever I'm not
getting misty-eyed dude now yes this
movie's a little different than the
usual movie reviewed by me but the
acting was good the characters were
solid the script was good the comedic
delivery was great although it's kind of
not really a comedy and Bateman and that
little kid just straight-up stole the
show now you might have to be 25 or
older to fully connect with this movie
but that's just a disclaimer
now what award does this movie get I
think it's worth watching no alcohol
required but if you're a dude you might
have to take a date just to justify you
going that is a fish killing bad actor
just really isn't your thing we all have
our scenes hey I have my excuse I do
these videos but if you don't have an
excuse you just might have to take a
partner in crime just saying but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more